check this out oh yeah what are we
checking out is it a magic show
it's a magic show look three two
one what's up guys today is gonna be an
exciting day
i am finally gonna break in my backyard
and by backyard i really mean my my
grill
i have a trigger grill over there it's
been sitting in
in and around our house for like a good
month now just because of the
construction of our backyard haven't
been able to grill haven't been able to
use it
haven't even been able to season it yet
so with barbecue you have to season your
grill before you actually cook it and
get rid of all the
the the factory greases and the unedible
fumes that will come out of the metal
and the plastic parts i guess so today
i'm gonna season my grill
and i'm gonna throw some meat on it and
see how well the trigger does
so breaking in the backyard so me and
tiff we've been chilling here
during the nights and the early mornings
before it gets too hot
out and it's really nice got this solar
powered lights
there's a switch here coffee in the
morning dinner at night
pretty sweet bam we got the traeger
we got the smoker it's been unused up
until this point so we're gonna break
that in today
and over here i also went just came back
from the store
and i'm gonna fill up this refrigerator
with drinks
it's the first time we've ever had an
outdoor fridge i'm kind of excited
for those of you guys that have had
outdoor fridges
this might be kind of basic too but we
always run out of room on the inside
fridge just because you know the amount
of food that we
have in there so it'd be nice to unload
all the drinks from inside and finally
load it up on the outside
[Music]
just took out all the stuff that was in
the fridge that were beverages
i'm gonna put that in here as well look
at this
i'm trying to make it look like a
grocery store nice and on display
for anybody that is thirsty
that was fun playing stock boy or the
house they did a pretty good job look at
the display so isaac has
his what he calls beers it is a beer
root beer and he only had two more left
so i stuck it up here because uh
we have some leftover perrier from our
cabin trip check out our cabin trip
video
in fact we didn't even like this lemon
perrier
everyone on the trip said it tastes like
soap and i have to agree with that but
i am not one to waste anything so we
took it we have it
and it might be here for a while or it
might be the first thing condom i'm just
gonna
try and soldier through drinking it and
just getting rid of it so we can have
more space with things we actually like
lemon perrier angry orchard which is his
favorite
favorite bottled alcoholic beverage i
would say classic coke we got cherry
coke
and we bought the small minis so we can
uh
ration our amount of sodas at a time
otherwise you're stuck with the full
sized ones and i always feel like i
can't even finish these the older i get
i can't finish the whole can
anymore like i probably drink up to like
here and then like
whatever's remaining here i'm just like
throw it away basically alcohol can be
down here
the sugary sodas in the middle and then
we got the
healthy no sugar added beverages
and i've been really liking the spin
drifts lately so move over lacroix you
are phasing out we're going spin drift
that looks pretty i like all right
speaking of the devil
you know i think i'm getting used to
this perrier lemon flavor
it does taste like so you know there's
like two different types of lemon
flavors that candy makers and drink
makers try to go after there's like the
jute lemon juice flavor
and there's the lemon zest flavor and i
think this is like the lemon
zest flavor it doesn't taste like lemon
juice at all it's like more of like that
that lemon zest that lemon skin flavor
but if you like detergent flavored
perrier lemon that's the way to go the
moment i've been waiting for
ain't she a beauty oh yeah home sweet
home
casey chan last time i grilled or smoked
anything was
has to be well over a year ago but this
is going to be a new experience though
so
prior to this i've always had like the
egg-shaped weber grill where it's like
stacked on top of each other and you
have like the fire and the bottom
smokes up into the water so it's like a
water pan
and i've always smoked my meats that way
and i've mastered controlling the fire
and the heat and the smoke manually but
this thing
this thing just does it all
automatically for you so this can this
is like a luxury to me
all right so the first thing we got to
do is take out
everything from the inside and turn it
on and
see if it even works
[Music]
this is what it looks like on the inside
so this is where you put the pellets
and it drops through there and it
somehow comes out
this way into there and it heats up
right here
and then all this stuff deflects and
reflects and whatever reflects
the heat onto the grates which then
cooks the meat
and then smoke goes out through here out
through this fancy little chimney
[Music]
look at that guy he's turning
really slowly oh yeah and i feel the air
here
the manual said that there should be hot
air coming out
and i'm assuming that it still needs to
heat up oh i smelled it it's heating up
with that slight burning smell
like the dust is burning in there or
something this is my favorite toy
that i've gotten for myself in a long
time this
oh i can see smoke i could see smoke
we got smoke wow
all right
kind of put these pellets inside the uh
what do you call this guy the pellet
holder i guess
it looks like dog food here you go
now time to crank it
all the way to the highest setting there
we go it's counting up there
all right so now that we've fired up the
grill and we know it works
i'm going to put in the hardware and to
uh
finally season the grill called a heat
baffle
and this is supposed to create an
indirect heat for the cooking process
all right so i got the traeger all set
up now
and i'm gonna let it season for the next
45 minutes
and then i'm gonna throw some meat on
there let me show you what i'm working
with today
so i got this chicken the citrus chicken
marinading i'm gonna throw this on the
grill later today so i'm kind of meal
prepping honestly because uh there's no
way we're gonna eat all this food
tonight so
steak is really expensive so i only got
one ribeye steak
then i got four bone in new york strips
and obviously there's less marbling here
so not as fatty and flavorful
as a rib-eye steak but this is gonna be
delicious regardless
because it's gonna be cooked in the
traeger and then i also got um
some portobello mushrooms that i'm gonna
cook and then i'm also gonna cook up
some corn and bam and then i'm making
rice and i'm gonna cook that with some
kimchi litter kimchi fried rice we're
gonna have steak we're gonna have
chicken we're gonna have corn salad and
portobello mushrooms and we're also meal
prep and hopefully this will last us for
the rest of the week because it is a
jake and newsweek
and once we get into the nitty-gritty of
jk news
i never cook during those days and in
fact i come home we we just sleep
and we go again the next day so we are
marathoning so we are marathoning the
food as well
are you hungry too you look weird in the
gopro her face gets long in the lens
[Music]
all righty the finished product we got
our steak over here
we got the chicken right here we got
some corn we got some salad
we got some kimchi fried rice smells
fantastic tiff are you ready for this
oh i'm so ready i'm trying to like fix
up this couch
in this living room so we can have nice
mood lighting like what we've been doing
true oh let me through this one how was
your day by the way
oh it was good yeah oh yeah yesterday i
was feeling kind of blue and like down
on myself because i didn't feel very
productive yesterday i don't know i do
that to myself
like if i didn't do enough or i didn't
feel like i did enough i kind of feel
down
so today i went hard did this vlog makes
food for my family
set up jk news found some jk news
articles are you okay you just up your
toe huh
[Music]
now that is the face we all can relate
to
but it's not just dubbing your toe it's
because my
my toenail and like an ingrown toe oh
yeah that that toenail
i'm sorry about that i need to
reschedule that podiatrist's appointment
because i scheduled it and i didn't make
it in the morning because i didn't said
an alarm and i forgot and i've been in
pain ever since and that was like three
weeks ago or two weeks ago
in short i feel i feel really productive
amazing dinner with the traeger trigger
trigger trigger
amazing i still got mushrooms on the
grill i forgot about the mushroom so i
threw that on just now
okay amazing so delicious thank you baby
check this out
oh yeah what are we checking out is it a
magic show it's a magic show
look three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
fancy
[Music]
this is sick i like it 360 turn bam
bam bam i like your contemporary dance
moves
[Music]
but yeah i love it look at this it's
amazing
the under the cabinet lights
these are a really nice touch oh color
temp
yeah there we go wait is that sam no
oh there we go you make a beautiful home
you're a good homemaker
thanks and you're a great chef thank you
good team
thank you all right and the person that
gets to enjoy it all
isaac dinner's ready
all right over and out
[Music]
me